everybody can you hear me fine
I just want to say right away I'm
absolutely amazed by the amount of
people who are in the chat right now
that's insane already thank you so much
guys
and yeah I'm super excited as well and I
have to say just in advance
it's a couple of caveats for one I
didn't actually play this game at all
before this I've had the opportunity to
I just wanted to avoid it just to be
able to really play this blind have no
idea what to expect no idea what to do
no idea if the controls are actually
exactly the same as planet coaster I
just got the sheet with the controls
here and it looks like it should be
about the same there's all bats then
there's the fact that they gave me a
German keyboard here because we're in
Germany after on German keyboards are
kind of strange they've got all kinds of
weird letters on them and the set and
the Y are reversed
but the settings on the keyboard are UK
so it's like oh I'm very glad that I can
I can at least type blind because I'm
gonna kind of need that
oh yeah and finally there's a lot of
pressure on me here you guys know that
I'm not too great at streaming there's a
reason why I'm a youtuber not a streamer
and I think events like these always
make me very conscious of that fact I
think streamers just somehow inherently
have a very different way of working and
whenever I've sent a stream in the past
it's usually just a reveal of how
terrible I actually am at video games
I think these youtube videos tend to
make it all look a bit better than it
really is
let's move
just 1 minutes
I'm not gonna do a countdown but I have
to say these screens actually really
cool I really
yeah the hype is definitely real
especially for everybody over here the
the vibe over it I I'm definitely gonna
talk a bit more about the whole planet
zoo booth but I've spent most of my day
today just going around the expo looking
at all the different booths that are
there and planets do is one of the bests
booths I've seen James Turner is on the
other side of the planet zoo booth so
yeah I can't really see him actually
from my perspective which is a bit
annoying
hmm but there are glass windows all
around me and lots of people can see me
right now so I guess it's time to go
into the screen everyone silver right
here and welcome to Lennon's ooh never
played this before and these are gonna
be my very first seconds of the game so
like I've written in the description
this is for me very much a test to see
how does this compare to planet coaster
obviously this is a new game but it very
much uses the same basic graphics as
sets controls all of that and I think a
lot of people from Planet coaster will
be wanting to step over to this game as
well special thanks to bow for these
ears that I've totally ripped off of her
head
I think they're really nice I think I'm
gonna keep them onto the screen and I
think what's gonna get them back but
yeah this is just my attempt to see how
does the game work I've never played
this before what kind of assets do we
have and how intuitive is it especially
since I've been thinking as somebody
coming from Planet coaster who is not
all that much into suits I have to admit
I'm just about as much in pursues as the
average
to what extent can you just get into
planets ooh and yeah get started because
it's really a question to what extent
controls and everything are the same and
what stuff is completely different and
what stuff has been added
[Music]
if you want the shirt I have no idea I
got it from a thrift store so sorry
about that I can't really give too many
recommendations there anyway let's get
started so we have some basic controls
over here we have selects cancel and
camera zoom camera rotate camera undo
redo race camera and locally so I think
that's all the same basic controls seem
to be next I mean object placement seems
to be next that's all the same we have
the advanced move tool classic that's
really good like the surface and
positions now so so far everything seems
to be the same lots of requests to show
us the giraffes oh god I have a giraffe
plushie just out of reach I wish I could
show it but unfortunately I can't
next we have the parts tool on
everyone's favorite part of planet
coaster but it seems to be back in just
the same way at least it'll be just the
same as in planet coaster I think one
slightly short but judging by the look
of the park over here it should be just
about the same
placing deleting adjusting etc yeah so
now I can hear the birds chirping and
all that it's really nice more controls
yeah I think this is all the same as
well we have the multi select tool
awesome classic animal camera controls
click on the animal camera and you can
find out guest insecurities so we have
security cameras
what else
zoo currencies cash cash is used to
build years of infrastructure and player
stuff you can earn cash from the shops
and best facilities donation boxes and
ticket booths fair enough
conservation credits conservation
credits allow you to adopt higher tier
animals into your zoo here's how to earn
them breeding animals releasing animals
into the wild and trading your animals
that's actually really cool so you'll be
able to have some kind of exchange
system with animals with other zoos
things like that so that's really
interesting
i'm also i've always been wondering how
they're gonna approach this whole angle
at this point I can admit this but I
remember after the the London tour of
the studios that was a part of the
Bronte development studios there was a
certain someone who was spoiling a lot
about the game that he was not allowed
to spoil I'm not gonna mention any names
but there was something about
conservation and possibly guests getting
angry if you don't read your animals
right which is super cool and I haven't
been able to talk about this so far but
now I can so there we go and personally
I think it's really interesting that
they're going into these kinds of
ethical issues the microphone is really
average and you move it closer this is
quite difficult the issue is that the
microphone is all the way over here so
this might be a bit better but the
camera is over dears
either I'm gonna be include the camera
or my voice is gonna be a bit more crisp
and I think I just want to be in you I
think the microphone should be alright
it's a really expensive microphone so
and I'm trusting it anyway moving on to
rate painting there are six core terrain
types we've got Rudy and the ladies
liner right in front of me putting crazy
faces and brand camera as well it's
going to be really difficult
concentrating with these people in front
of me but yeah moving on we've got grass
lawn grass dirt rocks and snow I'm
mostly interested in bond grass in terms
of how the 3d grass is going to learn
you really want to see my Tiger ears
yeah I could see that I like them too
technically I think they're still bows
but we'll see about that
after I'm done screaming and this is the
final page terrain stamp tool
crushers etc etc we've got a bit of a
glitch going on here I think this will
be a good time to remind everybody that
this is still a work in progress this is
an early build of the game so you might
be seeing some bugs and things like that
I have no idea but it might happen like
over over here hmm but yeah also they
gave me a list of talking points and I'm
really bad at listening off talking
points that I didn't write myself but
for the people who are wondering planet
2 is going to be released on the 5th of
November and it's actually much cheaper
than I was expecting it to be although
compared to planet coaster I guess it's
about the same but yeah it'll be 35
pounds and there's gonna be a beta as
well which is going to start from the
24th of September now all of that stuff
out of the way let's get actually into
the game and see what this is like and
I'm already confused I already have no
idea what's going on here
before I do anything else that I want to
look at the park I'm really curious
about the scenery pieces most of all and
in general about the graphics of the
game but already it definitely seems
like a step up from Planet goes through
and that's the one thing that honestly
I've been looking forward to because I'm
just mostly into architecture and
landscaping gardening and all these
kinds of things so what kind of pieces
we get and how good they look is
something that have been extremely
curious about but yeah it looks great so
far like I love actually I love the way
that the LOD is in the distance also
seem to yeah you can definitely see them
switching to LEDs but I think they look
better than the planet post ones I've
always had a bit of an issue with how
planet coastal trees look from a
distance but these ones so far seem to
look much better I think
are these new trees another juice the
oak trees I think a lot of foliage from
Planet grocer comes back but especially
when it comes to scenery and building
pieces I think we'll have
a bunch of new stuff like this under
British architecture over here these
typical chimneys the brick moves and the
windows all of this stuff just looks
really good
this balustrade piece is amazing
but on the Front's it looks especially
good I think
who they don't have any decorations on
the top
how did guests enter the map I had no
idea guess I'll see you later can we get
a close-up of the woman with the sign
I didn't see anybody with oh you mean
it's a guy with the sign I don't know
what he's doing this might be one of the
protesters yeah so this guy has been
protesting he's leaving the zoo now but
oh god that's all written in blank oh I
can't read that
and it's big blank oh I'm sorry but he
was clearly protesting about something
monkey related oh so this is the
entrance building right and then the
guests are coming in from these
buildings over here okay okay we have a
broken wall I've no idea how to fix this
but apparently there's a wall broken
right here can a man just get some
lighters and try to discover the game on
his own
uh here's the broken man although how
could you tell
are we just gonna ignore this for the
time being and keep going with the bike
tour
I probably shouldn't I mean these are
grizzly bears so I probably shouldn't
let a grizzly escape oh oh oh what do I
do
oh I can move in the liveries Oh God
okay you can't just simply move in what
do I do
I have no idea how to prevent this
catastrophe from happening here
did they plan this was this was this
part built just to have animals escape
right from the get-go oh they're going
back oh but the car isn't going back
though reah okay we got some really
interesting information though we are
here maple and there's this Zachary and
they're all doing well their wealth
that's social habitat is good and
Richmond is necessary right but first I
need to get these guys back how do I do
that
or maybe I shouldn't assume gender it's
a woman but I do I have literally no
idea just an FYI there is a tutorial in
the game I just decided not to do it I
decided to get into the game completely
blind on the assumption that nothing
would go wrong really but clearly that
was a terrible idea
[Music]
okay well maple isn't going anywhere yet
people are very afraid but they are
running towards the Dare that's that's a
good strategy
maybe another pair escapes no that
hasn't happened yet how do I do this
apply or remove concerts are oh that's
interesting that's not what I need
exports definitely not
maple was appealing but I don't think
she'll be appealing which is outside the
enclosure don't go any further away
please I need to figure out how to get
you back all right God how do I do this
we have animal alerts we have to escape
bears oh there's a button here oh that
just brings you to the animal
sooo alerts then I'll be general alerts
[Music]
sukhiya I don't know why I can't read
this but I feel like it might be useful
all right jets come on your boats are
just gonna let maple roam free and
explore the rest of the park or am I
gonna try my best to put her in the
enclosure again yeah move didn't end up
working because I had a move position
over here but as long as maple has been
escaping I don't think they can move her
I mean I could try again but yeah then
we get a delivery schedule
that doesn't seem to be to thank to be
free all right Chet has voted we're
gonna let the Bears run free and we're
just gonna explore the rest of the point
here's the thing I only have an hour I
want to discover as much about the game
as possible so let's keep going now this
is really cool and yes I'm ignoring the
Bears also this is really funny my
friends called free the bear
shoutout to free the bear your name is
becoming extremely relevant at the
moment but yeah this is super cool we
have multiple animals in one enclosures
I think it's just zebras and giraffes oh
yeah that's that's really cool the
plains zebra the reticulated giraffe
a little sprinkler over here that's
pretty cool
so that's what adds the enrichments it's
interesting but it's still it's still
not enough but it's something and here's
a puma trade it's also good to know this
is probably for the giraffes yeah good
page for the giraffes
needs to be filled apparently
and a viewing platform oh this is super
cool
this is actually really similar to I was
in the Prague zoo a few weeks ago and
they also have this very much raised
sueing platform jutting over the
enclosure it looks super similar to this
what else do we have in the enclosure
just general ground textures I'm gonna
get point off topic if you consider
animals the topic quite a few times here
I really like the the ground texture so
far they do seem to be much different
from planet coasters that's nice I was
kind of afraid that they would rehash a
lot of that swap and the rock work over
here looks really good and yeah it's
just pieces but they blend super well
with the ingame terraforming that's
something that I think none of the rocks
and planet coaster really do with these
ones like really have a transition from
terraforming into the book it's pretty
good we have some poop as well click up
it would be super cool if we could see
an animal food that would be really nice
all right these guys are fighting
ooh that's really low enrichment but
yeah I gotta say Rock work is amazing
ooh and I just reached 117 thousand
subscribers thank you guys I guess it's
not too much of a milestone but I
reached it during a stream that's
something that's never happened before
yeah the ground textures and rock work
that's absolutely amazing that that's
always looked a little bit cartoony for
my taste than planet coaster but here is
just transitions so well I really love
the second bounce as well here we have
tamarins oh I have no idea that tamarind
looked like this I have a jar of
tamarind paste in my fridge the moments
just the life updates white birch oh I
love this this person is actually really
nice
we have virtues of planet coaster but
this one looks way better
awesome three times at least
I wonder what this is this is the
station for the railroad train
we have Mon cher it's the brand's are
coming back it's been nice to see ya I'm
gonna what I'm gonna look around the
park first and then I'm gonna scroll
through the animal
catalog and the scenery and maybe even
some of the vines that when I we've got
some artificial snow in here which looks
quite good at least I assume that's what
it is a rubbing pets or the Snow Leopard
and we have these temperature centers
now I say that I haven't played the game
so far but I definitely have heard quite
a bunch of stuff about it one of the
things
and then we've seen a lot of updates
about this temperature and the fact that
temperature is gonna play quite a large
role especially for the animals that
live in very particular climates so it's
really cool to see that they have these
cooler kind
no idea how it would work I guess it
just kind of closed it down but in real
life sooo this is always an interesting
kind of predicament I know that in
Prague for instance they had a snow
machine in the polar bear enclosure
which was super cool to see and I've
heard from Joe well also shout out to
Joe that apparently in wild lands Emin
in the Netherlands they had like some
kind of technology hidden in the rocks
where they cool or heat the rocks
depending on the temperature and then
the lions can sit on them apparently the
Lions don't even use it that much but
it's interesting to see what kind of
solutions the sewers are coming up with
to make animals more comfortable and
often alien climates what is this the
keeper Hut's so I guess this is kind of
a stock room for the keepers it's very
well decorated I like the fence
what is that fence please okay I'm gonna
look at all the construction pieces
later it's interesting that it's called
construction because in planet coaster
we have buildings and scenery
maybe they both put them into one town
and all of this is backstage I believe
yeah this is all backstage stuff and
it's all kind of hidden from the guest
view but there's really the lots in here
we have research
that's quite important quarantine a
trade center so that's how that works
we have water treatments coming soon and
[Music]
another time
and yeah I didn't notice there was a
snow leopard in here but I didn't see
him outside I just see this guy walking
around this keeper here
oh yeah there they are
I love that even the air is waggling
that's money alright moving on these
building theses look absolutely amazing
I've always been
these glass pieces I remember it was a
big deal with planet coaster when glass
was finally added into the game but here
we start off with two glass pieces
already when you were in what Lance the
Lions did stick around the box so I
guess now you know why they do that
and yeah the pumping system seems to be
the exact same but I still try and
discover a bit about that yeah yeah I'm
just casually talking about the trees
and what work and foliage mama bear has
escaped I know we have some geometric
gardens in here and it looks very nice I
have to say did I miss any enclosures
because it looks like a bit of open
space here but that's going close
so I think the way that they designed
this level is just trying to keep
certain areas open to let people design
their own enclosure to do something like
that maybe this is what it could be used
for
can you the lady sign and really bring
him out to a collaboration
maybe we'll see
see I think this is the next thing
closure all of this area is room for
expansion I suppose
this looks like a really fast bowling
pin that's a skittle no that that's not
a skittle I was looking at this thing
apparently that is nice kidding I only
knew those as candies but sure
that's very interesting energy skates
are you kidding me
alright well moving on guys I'm gonna
look into that later after this dream
I'm gonna see how I can return animals
to their enclosure safely but for now
I'm just gonna turn this into its unique
experience you can really roam around
freely with the animals it's totally
unseen and unique in the zoo and so I'm
sure that'll be my major selling point
now there must be some kind of aquatic
no I bet this is the sea lions it has to
be right
it's funny these lights are very
recognizably from plymouth coaster see
anything
do they have an indoor section or
something like that
yeah this no idea
the hippo oh yeah that makes much more
sense because they don't really have a
indoor settings also why
see any opposed
did I just miss something obvious
all right I'm just gonna pull a door I
and say did you see the hippo and
so I think I'm just gonna
what else do we have but it is custom so
this is very modular that's good to see
anyway I'll look into that later as well
another station oh wow I really like
this building that looks pretty nice
this is a really big enclosure for the
elephants awesome
it's not a lot of elephants but they
definitely have my favorite enclosure so
funny this is a beautiful inclusion a
lot of water as well just one Imports
its relevance so that's good to see
a mother food too and that that walk
work that's awesome I just this this
whole viewing platform over here is
super cool
let me just do a quick experiment and
see if we can press T to go into the
free camp yeah there we go
awesome although it works big difference
we're still staying at the same plants
anyway that's interesting I don't know
if I like that we'll see if we got used
to it
[Music]
I'm just gonna say oh yeah it's a
different world yeah
[Music]
I don't think I've ever seen these at a
soup of hereby I'm not sure I don't
remember but this enclosure is clearly
not up to par oh God
and there are some social issues which
I'm wondering because that deviates per
animal now they all have the same value
so it just depends on
what's with the social issue because
seems to be quite a few typical ones in
here what's there a terrarium in the
building that's a really good question I
should probably take that out I guess
there probably was
looks like it just
yeah it's just an off going
there must be some buildings for
tomorrow himself oh this is really
interesting I've heard a lot about power
being a really important part of the
game
apparently it's coming soon so we don't
yes but we've got this
oh then we're protestors are the wolves
so I guess there really were some kind
of social issues
oh yeah and this is for the Tigers oh no
it's broke this thing the timber was so
the animal and the protests doesn't
really match up apparently what are they
protesting in flowers
it's definitely does social and whether
that's necessary for the walls many
timber wolf exploits impotence because
I'm just gonna move on
no idea how to attend to that issue oh
we have the Lions and they're doing all
right I do notice that enrichments is an
issue in a lots of places I also have to
say I wonder to what extent it is safe
to just have this glass over here this
looks very unsafe
a setup like this would be so much more
realistic with just this wall over here
check the drop-down menu in associations
oh oh that's interesting
so they don't have enough space right I
mean it's not cool that they don't have
enough space sorry that was really
poorly worded it's cool that you have
this drop-down menu to tell you exactly
let's go so that was that section of the
park
okay no maybe not this session
these are awesome these pine trees in
general I noticed that there are a lot
of new pine trees in the game we even
have a spot spine that's awesome those
say that actually looks really cool
really good though
oh we have the Bears so we didn't see
this before I just didn't notice the
pine trees here's the large enclosure
with these rocks and zebras I think
we've had the whole zoo at this point I
just haven't seen any indoor yeah I've
seen
is it possible to let the train crash
into the animal enclosures maybe I'll
start thinking about breaking the game
later for now I just mostly want to
figure out what's in the game where is
the wildfire yeah I I would I would be
super hyped if they added an r MC course
to mana know if they will
no I don't even know where the whites
are because we do have the steve-o
that's coming soon
and some zoos the enclosures was
separated by a canal
I don't know exactly how the enclosures
work but I definitely see at least
almost screenshots that they've revealed
so far sometimes that may look off the
enclosure with just scenery objects but
I don't know if that means that there's
a wall hidden somewhere or if you really
can just make a wall out of anything
I don't care I don't care too much by
the shops I'm sorry I just want to look
into what we have so first and foremost
I'm going to look at
is this fun at the park this is
sectionals
[Music]
how do I delete stuff
oh my god where's the Delete key on this
German keyboard
I have no idea
Oh contracts works interesting but
that's not what I needed to do no
actually that was cultural exertion
normally leads them control
he does the same
these controls are slightly different
but now I'm oh that's not it
forget about it I'm just gonna use this
as an empty space here
I wanted to what extent it matters what
kind of very amusing
you could use invisible Oh good points
I've got about that yeah
so here it is
[Music]
guest gates
airlock beach ball
okay so how does this fencing to work
oh-oh-oh and even those curves really
well and it's super easy oh it's nice
god this makes me wish we had this and
planet goes to anyway I'm I'm really
gonna need to figure out how to delete
stuff because otherwise this mic is
going to be a mess
last one
one-way glass
oh that's good
we have
box
I also like that it's slightly different
depending on which kind of fence you're
using like the wooden log doesn't allow
you to go curved
steel mesh red brick
however this is pronounced
oh that's those books in the mesh that's
pretty cool corrugated iron came the
electric with the dinosaurs I suppose
ENC f all right thank you you're an
absolute legend
that multi-select resilient yet and I
suppose
Oh Mickey
it's not mostly selecting the fences
maybe that's
difference
anyway
figure that out made of old and it
automatically deletes all of it that's
that's really intuitive that's good to
see
can we see some stop building interiors
- that's a really good point I do want
to look into that I'll do that in a
second here and yeah the way that it
transitions to 3d grass is really nice
as well like if you zoom out it just
looks regularly like 2d grass but as
soon as you zoom in you get that
beautiful 3d Ross that's pieces that we
get for the habitats we get their own
specific pieces now the way that this
works as far as I know is these pieces
are going to be climb about like they
can do anything with these and you can
lose the the modular 3d X's tool to like
place them any direction of place you
want I think yeah you can just go ahead
with these
it doesn't even necessarily needs to be
supported by gravity I suppose but yeah
that is super cool we have the undo
button as well as you can see the brain
kinda gets you going
but yet all of this stuff is claimable
and usable by the animals and certain
things will add enrichments obviously
certain things will allow you to feed
them so this will all just have to do
with the certain
means the animals
our objects move around with arrow keys
once selected
that's I don't think so I think it'll
just be the three deepest ammonia
you'll just have to press eggs
he gets mom here
quickly fine sixteen dangerous animals
have escaped that is truly epic alright
we're gonna keep going I'm just gonna
see what else we have in the game all
right now I'm super excited for this
I've seen a lot of flowers and little
plants and so far whoo this doesn't
disappoint
I have to say foliage is one of the
things that I found really disappointing
and planet coaster but my god this list
never ends okay I'm just gonna be really
honest and I want to be as honest as
possible about like what things I like
and don't like but this foliage right
here is like everything I would have
wanted out of Planet Ghost and I quoted
my major gripes with planet coaster this
foliage list is never-ending this is
awesome okay I wanna at least try like a
basic few types we've got a lot of
different flowers we can't recall her
them but I think that's totally fine I
mean there's just so much choice in here
and usually I don't really like recolor
both flowers anyway because you'll never
really get the right color if you figure
it out yourself and then look
palm trees are much better than a gonna
closer as well that's really awesome
we got the giant baobab tree of course
that's a classic the even more joy oh
this is a big one
constantly
and they're really small we have the
bear berry bush
the lions escapes SMS this is like
rollercoaster tycoon
diamonds Heights where unless you do
anything about its the coasters is just
gonna crash its nest like oh so this is
the tree that we saw so this is I think
this is the tree down so yeah that's
super awesome
and these poplars are pretty amazing is
their vertical ones they are perfect for
streets path side decorations stuff like
that this we've already seen we have
reads yeah we have reads that's awesome
it's also nice because you have so many
different biomes in here you can really
make certain areas of the park look
completely different just by using
certain types of cottage cherry blossom
tree that's awesome that looks really
good
I love the foliage so far
rent cameras looking at me oh yeah
that's awesome
some plastic flower beds I swear I'm not
trying to like appear to heights about
this but the foliage is like my most
anticipated thing already this is
awesome you can make some really
beautiful looking environments Gardens
whatever with all of this foliage God
who did they hire from Planet coaster
they had so little foliage like I
thought one of my concerns was that they
just didn't have enough people
experienced with it
but I don't know maybe something changed
at the company because this is
absolutely beautiful whoever did all of
this foliage thank you this looks really
good
I'm just randomly going through a bunch
of this these look see we have the the
tsipras as well but they look so much
better than they do in planet coaster
this is a huge improvement you can
really even see the individual needles
and branches it's much more detailed
also than kind of coasters for regionals
nice take bones desert Ironwood that's a
classic
but night we have so much grunts rubbery
as well I'm really happy with that as
well like that is absolutely necessary
for a good variation foliage
elm-trees all wow these are these are
beautiful that's really nice
Three's
okay I'm actually I'm not gonna go
through the entire list this is too much
there's no way that you can show each
and every one of these if anybody is
really into foliage feel free to pause
at any moment and see what's there or we
have some planters it's perfect
I see lots of plants that you put in
those motors now work
um oh the walkways been boxed by the
zookeepers oh that true we have less
let's get em boys that's nice
oh these are really amazing as well
and here's the oaktree and again it's
not just the oak tree from Planet kosu I
wonder what was up with some the
earliest screenshots because I swear I
could recognize some treats in there but
this is way
this is a much much better selection of
foliage are we even even a separate
mulch
wow that's dude that's perfect so you
can definitely make custom parties and
things like that with this given that we
have the food you get small small
scenery pieces you can just make your
own custom love to us with these these
multi piece
this is the kind of stuff that I'm
really excited to see because you know
all of the animals that we're getting in
all of that but I did not expect to get
all of this foliage I think this cactus
is non silent except the career plans
it's beautiful
no dick jokes enchants please you can
actually maybe do a surprisingly decent
bartender with some of these trees
of course we have some cats on
sit on our books I'm not going to go
into the rocks too much but you can see
also very different shapes and planets
ghosts they didn't reuse any of the
shades that I see shapes that I see so
far
different textures different shapes the
planets Botanical Gardens I've been to a
lot of Botanical Gardens recently
actually but I mean I don't think we
need planet Botanical Gardens
I mean I'm building a ski resort in
planet coaster you could very well just
build a Botanical Garden in this game
all of this foliage easily Swiss cheese
plants are these just okay
I've got the name for this but
they're definitely not as Swiss cheese
what else this is Sycamore that's nice
to see
that's what is this oh this is the ten
minutes really seen it what work
okay the hedges I'm really curious to
see how the hedges are then the coastal
ones are admittedly okay there's no no
improvement there
I'm sorry not a big plan but the
squirrels are really nice I like these
but yeah maybe you can build some edges
out there pieces as well who knows if
you don't care about the piece guns
like ok we're almost there wisteria
there any of my Demon Slayer viewers in
the shed right here Mysterio's are
awesome if you ever get chased by demons
to simply take some mysterious with you
so yeah this is awesome I love the
nature stuff and then we have facilities
oh god this is ok we're starting off
with the canopies because these are
important leaders so it
restaurants and picnic places we had
picnic tables that's a god it was
absolutely insane I can't remember when
it was exactly I think it was in the
frontier expo but when they announced
that picnic tables were getting added in
to plan of course some people lost their
minds it's funny how that was one of the
most nine things about the game kind of
stupid in hindsight but it was really
funny at the time
yeah well that's basically all of it
listen at ease God
okay I'll save the pink pieces for later
this is too much to look into right now
but as you can see there's a lot of
stuff here loss moves mental pieces of
this law so take blanks is it
recoverable
that's something to keep in mind
lots of fountain pieces that's good to
see
more planters these were also in the
other menu
the box its graphics
this is the return of monster cleats
painted to play a booth that's really
useful cutter is oh god this is too much
get through we have basic shapes again
that's nice to see and all kinds of yeah
about the animals I will just be
completely up thoughts like a set of
beginning of the screen I'm like not
nearly as much into zoos as I am into
theme parks and I'm really how even my
my theme park enthusiam started with
just a lot more architecture and
landscaping in all of that so I figured
there's gonna be a lot of people
streaming planet zoo in this whole
weekend and personally I want to focus
on the things that I am most
knowledgeable about that I'm most
passionate about which is all of the
architecture and foliage and all that
kind of stuff but if you're interested
in other things there's a whole list of
streamers who are all going to play this
game for the first time on this event
right now as we speak
Louisville Italy is close to be
streaming the game as well and I have no
idea what it's all about but it's
probably looking quite a bit more into
the zoo's the animals aspects than I am
but yeah this is just what I'm most
interested in so yeah I think you should
definitely leave if you're mostly
interested in the animals and don't
really want to look into the
architecture or foliage and everything
but personally I want to make sure that
I look into that stuff especially if
nobody else is going to look into that
because I know there are a lot of people
who are really interested in foliage and
architecture and all that who definitely
want to see all the new pieces that
we're getting
which I'm also getting that feedback a
bit in the tennis ball thank you guys
so yeah just the heads up and I'm not
going to pretend like I'm a zoo expert
here because I only have general
foundational knowledge and it's
something that I'm just gonna
I'm going to I'm not going to go to the
into the building fight right now but I
will say I have multiple streams this
week and I'm actually gonna have to look
up and really quickly when else I'm
going to scream but I'm gonna scream
four times today included so you're
gonna see me quite a lot and I cannot
save the game so I don't want to build
anything and continue with it later
because saving is something that has
been added into the game yet so I do
want to focus on different things in
every screen so today I just want to
look around and see what's there in
another stream or maybe try building
something and look more into the
building pieces
I'll try looking into the animals at
some points and see how the animals are
managed how I can prevent animals from
escaping because that's quite a problem
here and we'll see how it goes
as we
this and yeah I'm going to I'm going to
go through the catalog definitely I'm
just looking up really
when else I'll be streaming as well I
got it here but yeah we're at the
building at the bottom of this here some
basic parts mix all rights and some
terrain options these are very much
similar
although it's interesting that you can
switch between short glass which is
regularly
long grass which grows like that oh
that's awesome so you can even thin it
out a bit you that's actually really
cool
so you can like kind of differentiates
and transition between the times of gas
so I'll be streaming as well on
Wednesday from 2:00 to 3:00 p.m. and on
Friday from 4 to 5 and finally on
Saturday for 2 hours from 1 to 3 p.m.
and this is all European Standard Time I
haven't put anything on my Twitter yet
but I'll actually tweet this out just in
case so you can remember it as well and
otherwise there's a Giants catalog with
all the different people who are
streaming and at what times they're
streaming on your website as well so
yeah I still want to look into the
buildings and then the animals as well
so I guess
I miss the lemurs where are these
or is it pronounced no sir that's a
british-american thing isn't
all they're over here
[Music]
yeah
yes they're all hanging out here yep
those are not all of them
well the Tiger ears remain on your head
for the other strings I have to ask beau
about that I suppose
[Music]
Oh foxy is back oh that's awesome
did you see her anyway I'm looking for
where the animal section is
you know where you can like see you all
the animals there okay so I definitely
miss the lots we have her loss so we do
have some oh here it is now it's looking
for these
we have a bird eater exhibits
I suppose Carlos is here Lehman's
Robinson
a birthday you can also selectively make
these balls class or well a wall that's
pretty cool to see as well
I didn't see the yellow anaconda but
that's just another exhibit piece so
that's not really any closure
although I do wonder to what extent
these are customizable okay so you can
enrich them certain types basically
that's interesting
SPR I have to say oxy is my favorite
mascots but maybe I'm biased but I
really like your design
apparently rule 34 also like to the
design I hope you haven't seen those
pictures but I mean I guess that's
flattery that's a form of flattery it
really has a good design
I honestly think she's one of the more
popular characters maybe even if I GM
didn't like them
we have something policy that
the tortoises will probably have their
own larger habitat one day oh these are
just scattering around here that's
really cool
it's not exactly open I was in awe
what's that place called again
Holland Park the moment recently and
they had so many peacocks over there
that's really cool
what else do we have
yes I wanted to go to the tortoises
right yeah so these have their own
house performance I have to be honest
I'm not a query I have to be honest it's
nothing wrong with being a very
versatile of course I have to be honest
this computer is not a good indicator of
what the performance of the game will be
like and where this has a 20/20 this is
a to atti graphics card and it has i-94
i-96 what am I saying
so yeah it's not really good imitation
performance is going to be on the
average computer on my side it's
absolutely perfect nighttime really good
points
why this is not nighttime this is the
radar to see your animals also super
useful this feature is really cool you
can basically find out where your
animals are how they're doing so if you
ever need to find an animal
super useful I've heard there's a slider
now for the time of day but how does
that work there we go so instead of just
manually editing the time you can just
have a slider which is absolutely
awesome like in planet coaster you would
have to enter the numbers at the
annoying you're gonna be able to tell
right away how it looks but here you can
go right away to the right time
especially oh wow that bloom okay that's
that's really cool but especially if
you're like alright I want to take a
picture of Pope this building oops but I
want to have like the right lighting you
can just look at it and be like
[Music]
and sunset looks beautiful as well
huge improvements over Lenin's coaster
in terms of graphics too
this looks so cool just watching this go
up and down
Emmet that lentil oh this is the exit
area
how big is the map that's a good
question
okay I'm gonna go back to midday
actually so it's quite sizable I think
but it's hard to see where exactly what
it is yes the borders over here I think
this this su over here fills out the map
quite neatly I have to say though I like
the surrounding area a lot this really
looks like a British with generic
European kind of landscape all the wind
breaking rows of trees and just there
woman yells in the distance it's like a
really nice map what else would I think
I've checked out all of the animals that
way
did I
that's a lot of animals
finances oh that's is you help you
Sylla tees I still want to look into
facilities I had five more minutes I'm
gonna try my best and see what else is
interesting that I should look into we
have this little camera
is
all right I didn't do anything guess
we'll find out later yeah that's right
we're in Texas already
gonna be pretty much the same as planet
coaster
wait
animal trading very good points
oh so this is where you can find out
what kind of course makes
all right so I'm actually gonna try and
see what else we have for thoughts
ostriches Timberwolves
[Music]
what is the place of every in the game
that's not okay but what is special
about this these medals
I can't wonder what in this station
so
I don't know this this is nice to be
something in terms of
I have no idea
source customs seizure
rescue
it's really cool that like a lot of
these will be traded with yeah other
zoos or breeding programs
I guess we're ostriches that make sense
yeah it's really cool then you can get
these from different kind of places
it must make it difficult to start out
with a zoo like
with the theme part you can just start
down and build a few
get going from there but because
Hewitt's let me know they're gonna take
a lot of planning to be able to get the
right animals that you want or need
from all kinds of places
how many animals can you see No
and then you can buy them for a
sacrifice
weights and this is oh I wanted to see
what the leave maths but I just bought
me tourism what else do we have animal
trade center
[Music]
stop building interiors but that's the
one thing that I still need to go into
so we have some stock buildings here
this one doesn't happen in Syria
our identity okay so it seems like some
of them will have interiors and some of
them want to have the keeper huts and
the workshop and these will both have x2
interiors so only the buildings with a
window
so--that's oh and whether that's a
really good point oh god where's whether
I'm not sure if I could oh here we go
alright I have two more minutes let's
see that cloudy weather
I think it's slowly transitioning
yeah I think it is oh that's pretty cool
I can slowly see the clouds getting
bigger in the sky there
I think it's transitioning isn't it yeah
now it's cloudy that's really nice I
just want to see a nice I know
we have no clothes
I don't think I can see all of the
different types of animals that are in
the game right now because I can only
see what's in the park and what I can
trade
yeah the clouds are beautiful that works
great and if you make it rain it's just
gonna fill up really quickly and just
like that and people are whipping up
umbrellas
it looks great
and there's a professor's over here
[Music]
just overall like all the textures James
you have like reflective textures
everywhere you have the animations of
the rain coming down off the ground
that's awesome let's make it snap it's
it's time for me to stop but yes
so that's the lighting is beautiful
and the ground is still wet I think okay
so do we see the snow like dropping that
no
you already see the snow oh no it
actually remains that's awesome and now
I just got a slowly increasing layers do
that
this node just a graphics the weather
all of the new building elements that's
absolutely awesome and it even it stays
on everything it stays on the scenery
pieces on the statues I don't even know
how they did all of this dude oh my god
that's awesome Wow I I don't even know
how they did this
did they make like separate models or
they must know they must look like some
kind of I'm not an expert on that but it
looks awesome like even when you zoom
out everything gets kind of foggy as it
should when it's snowing as you see just
oh and I could slowly see the trees
getting more and more snowy Wow
yeah this is awesome just this the
weather and the graphics and the scenery
pieces are just so amazing looking like
they really stepped it up with this one
I want to go back to the rain though
because I really want to see just how it
interacts with the environments with the
animals even like if they actually go
inside or what they do with this kind of
weather
yeah so somebody said that they actually
see the water running off the walls boys
have got some z-fighting here and going
no yeah this is let's just related to
this specific bill I just the whole look
of the water running okay I think people
are signaling for me to stop right
okay now they're just giving me thumbs
up thanks for nothing but yeah this
looks awesome it's not quite running off
the water oh it oh my god okay that's
awesome
it's running off the roof Wow yeah I
guess I guess this is gonna fry my
computer isn't it
we'll see how that goes anyway I'm gonna
need to end this stream here
this is all I've got I've got one hour
for now but be sure to tune in tomorrow
and also on Friday and Saturday I'll be
streaming as well so yeah hopefully we
can continue the shenanigans and I'll
try to take care of the animals I cannot
let them escape and actually focus on
their well-being for once anyway thank
you guys for watching it's been
absolutely amazing I am actually
honestly very positively surprised I was
expecting it to be a step up from those
but I definitely wasn't expecting all of
this and yeah I hope to see you guys
soon thanks for being here and I don't
know I'm gonna need some time to
properly work through all of this
maybe I'll bar it on to somebody else
anyway hi guys